[Music]
hi reject nation greg alba here the hump
we are going to watch honest trailers
double feature grindhouse over here Tomb
Raider and Pacific Rim uprising it's
kind of funny actually because last week
we did the honest trailers for Jurassic
Park 3 did a little commentary on it but
before that we didn't unboxing for
Pacific Rim uprising goodies from game
flying Universal home entertainment
thanks guys so we got these nifty
t-shirts Friday to go check out that
video later ok let's do a page of the
day shout out for a man named John
Minnie John Minnie is a lovely guy from
New York hardcore Democrat he did not
vote for Trump I want that to be cool
with everyone I don't want to have any
politics involved in our channel but he
did not vote for Trump he hates him
actually I'm not trading an enemy here
and I'm telling truths just like his
president Trump necessary John I'm glad
you got a new job buddy when I go to New
York I'm definitely gonna ask you for a
discount at that new pizza place you are
working now I like a solid cheese pizza
there's nothing like New York Pizza I am
told and have also experienced once and
I hope you satisfy your wife tonight
because she needs it hope that when the
Yeager future arises your drift
compatible with me dude ah
[Music]
you enjoyed a few parts of one and some
parts of the other went to popcorn
movies are so aggressively okay there's
only enough to say about them to make
one honest you know you want to see
Black Panthers dead anyway and perfectly
fine moderately entertaining films that
exist for the least exciting reasons
Time Warner's legal department acquired
and established IP for Paramount and
Comcast accountants notice one of their
movies over performed in China a step
you know someone had a new story to tell
or something to say about the world or
yeah I know I sound like my grandpa I'll
just be in the shed working their butts
off to make these franchises a thing and
Japanese MacGuffins into the store with
fun opening sequences this sin and the
by-the-numbers action and end with a
tease for a sequel that'll probably
never come thanks Ron Perlman and
Charlie Hunnam are gone we're left with
Pacific been very reluctant
shut up I can't do that if you get
peanut gums when he sent secret
information from a dead family member
he'll team up with an assortment of
heroic Chinese people to save the world
and send a practical robot battles that
are so insanely destructive there won't
be much of a world left to live in
either way no no but it's nobody
now that Angelina Jolie John Boyd and
joram or no God we're leather boy after
an orphan who gets in over her head way
over her head when she says attention
from a dead family member guilty the
assortment of heroic Chinese people you
wish they left her is Laura Croft
GrubHub delivery biker
anyone can read it - hiding Chipotle
from Midtown to the Bronx in 20 minutes
or less no that is exciting what no -
blockbusters are exactly alike
God is the female objectification from
the first Tomb Raider opposite rim picks
up the slack I find that to be
interesting while the other as a villain
too silly to be believed I'm ending the
world where uprising would have been
better there was more prouder than
reality
while Tomb Raider will get better with a
little more fun or three big dinosaurs
or something over the next time all the
new relations are checked out of
residences or you accidentally leave
effects on on a Sunday afternoon you
can't go wrong settling on the movie
based on the video game that was trying
to look like a movie or the movie trying
as hard as it possibly can Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
starring - the zoom his third by the
rules' military characters hahahaha bent
across a waste of a perfectly good Rico
all boys no principles Big Daddy
ah mr. Keith woods and burn gorman
tonight a fairy name but nope his nose
actually at burn gorman gospel epic true
upriver we're not the only ones who
cross tombraider with another movie the
poster mixed it with Jurassic Park just
like me - cheese in my pads get it out I
have your wife I'm the greatest good you
are ever gonna get lost of aw he stood
by bay turn on your voice chat it's kind
of fascinating to see how they're
similar and how they also could have
borrowed from each other simultaneously
and like switching some tones out like
we were talking about if you grounded
Pacific Rim a little more it could have
been better or if you height in Tomb
Raider could have been better personally
I mean I've said it before I really
liked Pacific from uprising I actually
on an enjoyable atif actor I really
enjoy uprising more it's still my
favorite video game movie but I think
Tomb Raider is the best video game movie
has been made so far I think they're
both good and I guess like saying
they're they're both just okay sure but
I think there's plenty of fun to be had
from both of these films I would call
them both pretty good yeah can I bet
there's great things in each of them I
would bump each up to a three and a half
and yeah I agree with you it's like I
enjoyed both of these a whole lot just
the watching experience and I do think
that each brought at least something
interesting - oh yeah doing and avoided
being generic or boring or whatever
I mean generics really thin words that I
remember both of these viewing
experiences they haven't just kind of
faded into the blur yeah yeah drew oh
yeah they're not just utterly disposable
films yeah you know when you're doing
this double feature honest trailer thing
you can't get it to any compliment
territory it's pretty hard to so you're
going to stick to your ribs but like
Alicia vikander to me and Tomb Raider
was awesome yeah kill them it's funny
when they take a compilation of all the
screams of how it seems goofy
[Music]
yeah what don't you watch it in the
movie you're like that's pretty cool
it's like it's like the games reliving
the compilation reminded me that much
more of the game which is kind of a good
thing yeah yeah especially when they do
that like shot by shot with the game
footage of her hanging off the plane and
falling and then showing the movie
footage I'm like you know that'll China
thing we noticed this did above average
in China so here we go like that's
that's become such a trend like I always
wish I got out of the shower I always
think it would be funny like we don't do
that for other countries we don't be
like they put Americans in this French
movie we gotta support it the
comparisons of this person stumbling
into a situation and then having a pair
up with Chinese people
it's very pandering to China what our
blockbusters do now and I yeah you know
I think with films like this I don't
even really care uprising it didn't
bother me I'm like this is so obviously
trying to get the Chinese yeah and I
don't scoff as much because there is an
Eastern influence on the big robot big
ass or kaiju Jon rrah anyway and it's
the best way we're gonna get Asia
involved in our American films right now
this is a hundred percent financially
motivated it's at least nice to get the
diver yeah while we're at it now as some
other Asian countries can be involved I
do have to agree with in that Rinku it's
a bummer that she does get killed off
yeah she's like one of the highlights of
the film and she's one of the few
characters they brought back they just
kind of kill her off yeah I'm always
especially baffled by that when they
bother to bring a character back from
the first one only to give them a few
minutes screen time and killed off yeah
I always gotta really suck for you as an
actor and I do wonder they made a good
point I do wonder if they're gonna get
sequels at the end because they both
have very obvious sequel setups both
endings I don't like I actually don't
like both endings of these movies yeah
because of the fact that i'm likejust
you should just enter your movie you do
a post-credits scene if anything I know
you don't want to be like Marvel but
you're essentially being like Marvel's
something I get it just because you put
it before the credits roll does not mean
you're not trying to copy the Marvel for
me I don't like the ending of Tomb
Raider because the movie went so out of
its way to really be faithful to its
reboot games and then show how different
it is from the Angelina Jolie ones and
then it ends in a way where it's like
now we're going back to the Angelina
Jolie
why you don't like the two guns it's
cool trailer moment but in the movie I'm
like with these kind of undos a lot of
this new image you're trying to portray
now yeah that's fair I mean I think
between the two of them I would rather
see another Tomb Raider that I know
definitely the grim and like in terms of
the setups I didn't like either set up
for the sequel but I feel like I like
the Tomb Raider set up a little more
than I like yeah those two mary has it's
kind of like saw thing going on about it
I don't care about that play yeah yeah
and I feel like with Tomb Raider it
would be easier just to be like we're
just gonna go on another adventure
yeah thanks crew I feel like Tomb Raider
leaves flexibility to be like oh we
don't need to do that as our second
premise sure oh alright guys well what
do you prefer Pacific Rim uprising or
Tomb Raider leave it in the comments
below
are you for black guys or female leads
yeah that's what this all comes down to
where's she from like Sweden or
something yeah yeah she's hot she's
quite attractive married to that guy
from shame you guys can't subscribe to
the reject nation you can click that
notification bail because subscribe
buttons are broken check us out on
patreon full like TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is would love to have you
become a patron eject to die